well as some of you may have noticed I
have two videos of Sherlock Holmes up on
my channel or as others of you may have
noticed I have two because one of them
was straight-up gone for a while either
case is a simple case of the man
exercising extreme douchebaggery okay so
last week I upload my Sherlock Holmes
review and life is good and about a day
or two later I get a notice on my
YouTube channel saying that a studio we
wouldn't want to name them by name now
would we
so we'll just call them studio weenie
biscuits they filed a copyright
infringement case against me and YouTube
pulled my Sherlock Holmes review because
of it but I didn't infringe any
copyright at all yeah it was some
[ __ ] in fact I'm pretty sure I'm
careful about not putting any copyright
material in my videos specifically to
avoid cases like that so what was it
exactly I mean did I say something in my
Sherlock Holmes review that might have
pissed off a studio since any second now
a bootleg collage Robert Downey jr. is
great as Sherlock Holmes moments is
gonna hit the web I just say watch that
oh did that offend you studio if I'd
known I would have just put it in there
are a hundred times over and now I just
gotta assume that the process for this
[ __ ] copyright infringement case
went down something like this ah do
people think of her latest film Sherlock
who Shh directed by the guy he directed
just for him but since any second now a
bootleg collage of Robert Downey jr. is
great as Sherlock Holmes moments is
gonna hit the web I just say watch that
huh I don't know you can always watch
that second now a bootleg collage of
Robert Downey jr. is graded I just say
watch that or I just say watch that to
watch that you watch to watch that come
on answer answer hi yes sir sir so we
have a bit of a problem no my ass
doesn't hurt that much little bleeding
but I told you not to use the pineapple
that's not the point
live at the sky on the internet I just I
kind of repeat it here a second now a
bootleg collage of Robert Downey jr. as
great as Sherlock Holmes moments is
gonna hit the web I just say watch that
or did you hear did you hear it
his name is Jeremy Jeremy Jan's
John Stehr however it was actually kind
of handsome but oh okay you can't just
say things like that don't like it's a
free country or anything but a cop
copyright claim yeah
well sir he hasn't actually infringed
any copyright so there's no rope can you
not be so pushy at work did it know what
you look here we go copyright claim it
is and it is done there is video it'll
be down within the hour
stomp it on the little guy a lot what
lousy always there it's a hard world out
there
stop your belt what I gotta go alright I
I stop it I gotta go
okay now you hang up first
now did you hang up first yeah and then
talking to a couple of people on this I
guess studio stomp on people all the
time on here
the big guy goes unchecked wielding the
power to throw [ __ ] copyright
infringement cases on people
resulting in account closures and tears
and for those of you who don't know if
you're seeing is a repeat offender your
account will be closed and you lose
everything which has happened well not
this time because I saw this notice and
heard the faint chimes of Public Enemy's
fight the power playing in my head so I
can test it I fought that [ __ ] and won
boom wow that's a proud moment for me
sue me but from now on I will try not to
offend Studios but since any second now
a bootleg collage of Robert Downey jr.
as great as Sherlock Holmes moments is
gonna hit the web I just say watch that
how did that get in there so the lesson
for us today is that if something bigger
than you or any douchebag for that
matter tries to stomp on you like that
[ __ ] and the lesson for the Goliath of
the world is that if someone
says something you just don't like well
choke it down like a man because even if
you don't like it it's still not
copyright infringement but in the
meantime be sure to click on the link in
the sidebar and subscribe to my channel
to see more videos sure to piss off more
studio execs and Twilight fans but might
still make you laugh and remember if
someone tries to screw you fighting
unlesss Giada De Laurentiis
in which case just let it happen yeah